if i tell you that i've drawn a triangle
with sides two centimeters three
centimeters and five centimeters then am
i telling you the truth or is it a lie
well it's impossible to draw a triangle
with sides two three and five why so for
that we need to understand the triangle
inequality theorem which says that the
sum of any two sides of a triangle will
always be greater than the third side
so let's see what happens in this case
let's take the sum of any two sides say
two plus three your two plus three gives
us five
don't forget what the theorem says it
says that it should always be greater
it cannot be less than or equal to the
third side
hence it is impossible to draw a
triangle with sides 2 3 and 5 units
now what if i say that the size of a
triangle are 3 4 and 5 is it possible to
draw such a triangle
4 plus 5 is 9 which is greater than 3
and 3 plus 5 is 8 which is greater than
4 in this case the sum of any two sides
is greater than the third side
it means it is possible to draw a
triangle with these dimensions
so is the triangle with sides 4 4 and 8
possible let us know in the comments
section and do subscribe to our youtube
channel for more such interesting
concepts